i can tell you that for me i try to
really balance both because
i'm kind of a nerd so it's important for
me to
to put the effort
[Music]
thank you so much for being on my show
how are you i'm good michael so great
being here well obviously you're good
because you're
at the gsb right behind you now you're
not actually
outside in front of the gcp but you are
in very close proximity right
yeah that's true i'm on campus right now
actually i live here so it's really
really nice
it is though sunny as you can see in the
picture so
i like it it is no no it's beautiful
actually you know i think this episode
is
likely i think it airs in about december
so i'll be getting ready to come back to
campus but you've had the privilege of
being on campus throughout
a lot of this coveted situation so i'd
love to both you know talk about your
journey going from 8 200
to to different startups as qa to google
and
now most recently stanford graduate
school of business but i'm particularly
interested to hear about
the how you know you've dealt with covid
as part of this incredible business
school program
and what the gsb is all about anyways
maya take me back first of all who is
maya all the way back to the 8200 days
and and how do you go about this path to
end up at the gsb
wow okay so that's a lot so let's start
and if you want to stop me just feel
free obviously
so i think um actually maybe i can start
even from my high school
um at high school i was a dancer
actually which is
pretty far away from everything that i'm
doing today i loved it
very much um and then when it was time
to get to go to the army
like everyone in israel when you get to
the age of 18 you have to go to the army
i really wanted to do something super
meaningful
um so i decided like to drop my dancing
kind of path
um and i went to 8200.
8200 for me was the first time that i
fell in love with technology this is how
i see it
um first time that you are exposed and
very young age to
really some crazy things that we can do
thanks to technology
um i spent there three years and i
really knew that whatever i'm going to
do next is going to be around technology
i didn't know what i'm going to be but i
knew technology
will definitely be a part of my life
going forward
um and then yeah and then after that
i did like you know
like every israeli i went to central
america
did a few months there like cleaned my
head thought about what i wanted to do
when i came back i decided to start
engineering in tel aviv university
and while i was doing my engineering
degree i started working at google
and that was like a very meaningful stop
in my way i spent there six years i
absolutely loved the company
and after six years i felt like there
are a lot of things out there
that i don't know and i'm not really
sure how i'm gonna explore those things
and then i started to think about doing
an mba and for me one of them
i do want to make i do want to to
mention here because this is a
a little bit divergent from from what a
lot of people around the world
experience because
usually when you go to college and you
study whatever it may be you don't go
and work full-time at a company
especially not a company like google
while you're studying and it's a little
bit different you we go to the army
and you spend quite a few years in the
army whether it's two
all the way to you know some people six
and then by the time that you go to
college you're mature enough to both
handle a full degree which is extremely
intensive three-year program in israel
along with a full-time job for four
years if you're doing the engineering
uh uh and juggling google so i think
that's amazing
yeah so um i started working at google
and my second year
of the university so it was really
challenging but i can say that
google is such an amazing place in the
sense that um
like my first my first conversation with
my manager was okay
um we want to keep you like th the top
of your class
so it's very very important for us that
you
keep like putting the the effort that
you need in in university and whatever
you need
um so that was really amazing to kind of
combine the both
sure so so talk to me about this how do
you think about going through an mba
because you're spending six years at
google
you're doing really you're really
amazing work there i
saw you quite a few times at google for
startups building uh
you know just in the months leading up
to stanford but what makes you want to
go do an
mba stop your career wherever it may be
and go
become a student again yeah i mean i
think the
first question um that a lot of people
ask
themselves is whether or not mba really
worth it you know it's exactly how you
said you take
two years break from everything you're
doing in your life like the the
opportunity cost here
is so big um you're losing two years of
salary you're losing two years of maybe
promotions and like what you're gonna do
next and a lot of people feel like maybe
it's not
the best choice like it really depends
of who you ask
and i totally get that to be honest um
you need to sacrifice a lot but then
again
you have to ask yourself why you want to
do it and why you actually are doing
that
and i think that for me the answer was
first of all as i started to say i
wanted to explore more options
here at stanford do it like i think
about everything
that i did last year i'm now on my
second year so i think about everything
that i
i did last year where in my life would i
have so many opportunities
just kind of squeezed into this one year
that
i think about all the things that i did
last year um
experiencing uh vc um in different tech
companies in product and things that
i never did before so for me first of
all it was like a safe
space to explore other things that i've
never done
so that was first the second thing that
i think is even more
important is thinking for the long term
and this is this is like the main reason
why i'm here because
thinking for the long term i think about
who am i
as like first of all employee but after
that as
also maybe a leader a manager what do i
bring to the table
and i think that in terms of my skill
set i really wanted to make sure that
i have like um a very diverse skill set
and i wanted to make sure that
when i when i want to be like a manager
maybe a founder going forward
i bring to the table valuable stuff both
in terms of skill set but also who
am i as a person what my values are
and stanford is a lot about the values
and who you are as a leader what kind of
things are important for you what kind
of thing you want to
push forward and i think that the last
thing that kind of brought me here
was the community um in a second
you are part of this amazing community
of like
the best people um here in silicon
valley the israelis are like a very nice
um
uh group that we all know each other so
i have to ask you
i have a few you know short questions
and answers because i think that
it's it's really it's incredibly
important to understand the context of
what a business school environment is
like i did not go to business school
myself not yet at least
but i did get to experience from the
side and you know just you know
hanging out with you around campus
because it's especially at stanford it's
like all intertwined we sometimes go to
the same classes
uh i believe that you went you took a
class recently with my girlfriend right
and she's in the graduate school so
quickly you know what
what who is the type of person that you
would find at the gsb
give me some high level characteristics
what are they like
you'll find all types of people really
but the best ones um that's like very
exciting
is that the most hardworking the most
humble the nicest
what does it mean the best people i
think yeah
the most humble i don't know if the most
humble but like
definitely people around here are very
humble
um all of the things that you said like
everyone is coming from a very different
background
having like a different background i
mean both industries but also from
everywhere in the world so yeah a lot of
hard-working people
doing their best you know to to excel
and be the best in everything that
they're doing
but also there is a huge emphasis of
what kind of person you are
um and like being good people being good
friend
um what kind of values are important for
you these are
things that we talk a lot about here um
and it's
and actually you know one of my one of
my impressions
by meeting a lot of the people in your
cohort is that every single person is a
leader in their community
and when you say you know the best
people what i'm thinking tonight is
whatever your circumstances were you
made the most out of it and beyond and
you've excelled in your circumstances
you've helped improve the lives of
others
talk to me so you mentioned you know
being good people and being in touch
with yourself
touchy feely i heard about that class
from so many different people
why is this a good representation of of
what the gsb encompasses
so touchy feely the the official name of
the class is interpersonal dynamics
i'm just taking the class right now
this quarter um and yeah it is it is a
very special class
uh you spend um a lot of hours per week
um with a very small group of people and
basically
it's kind of a safe place to work on
your communication skills
and how do people like feel about
specific actions that you're doing
and it helps you understand um
what kind of message you deliver to to
the other side and maybe how can you
improve
and be more efficient in the things that
you want to
say and how you're you're saying that
it's actually really interesting because
all the alarms the israeli alarms at
least that i i met like a year ago
even some that um graduated like 20
years ago
all of them are saying that this was
like the most meaningful experience for
them
uh from the gsb so yeah so i'm doing it
right now so maybe we can speak like in
a few weeks to see whether or not
it's the case for me i guess it will be
so in a higher level
you know you're thinking about graduate
school of business at stanford and all
of a sudden you have a class which is
all about
working on your personal skills and you
know people call it touchy feely and
it sounds to me like you know my
perception of the business scope until
now was you're coming you're learning
how to do accounting you're learning how
to hire people how to fire people and
how to raise money
but it sounds like it's a little bit
more complicated than that what what do
you
get out of a business school program and
and this is especially i think important
because it's it's sort of like a black
box to a lot of us in the undergraduate
world
who don't really understand what is why
would people go to an mba
when now there's a lot of movements that
are saying maybe you can just go into
the business world and get those skills
yourself
yeah that's that's a great question um
so i think first of all the beautiful
thing about stanford is
from your second quarter here you can
choose
a electives and you can build your own
schedule
and kind of focus in things that you're
interested the most
so depending on what your goals are like
people are coming here
wanting to be better in finance in
investing people are coming here but
wanting to
build their own startup and learn more
about entrepreneurship and vc
so it really depends on what you want
but you can get everything
honestly um so it's like one of
probably one of my advices would be to
come here
a little bit focused on what you want to
achieve here
because otherwise you can really like
get lost in all the things that you can
do here uh but you can really get it all
so there are a lot of people here that
are working on their startups taking a
lot of entrepreneurship
classes meeting a lot of different vcs
you know the guests that are coming to
our classes
now it's on zoom so well you know
less but um the people that are coming
to our classes are
amazing like the people from the best
vcs entrepreneurs that did
like sold one two three four companies
in millions of dollars can tell us all
about their path
um other people that are coming from pe
private equity and other investment
background can get a lot of background
about
finance accounting all the things that
you did and
everyone are putting a lot of effort
also in the more soft skills so
presentation skills communication skills
role playing about like
having difficult conversations and stuff
like that which is like
i i really like this um so we you can it
really depends on what you're interested
in but
you have here everything honestly
wonderful okay so one more question
about that just been then i'd love to
also focus a little bit about who you
are and and some of the things that
you're really passionate about
but first how much do you actually work
in the gsb
like how much of it is actually you know
doing homework sitting down
solving problem sets like i'm doing now
23 hours a day
in the undergraduate world versus you
know the networking in the community
yeah so once again it's it's a question
of who you are and what's important for
you
people who came here and want to put
like 100 in the
academics part can spend i don't know 20
40 hours a week just doing homework and
working for classes
other people i think most of the people
who came here came more for the network
so
it's really important to get to know
people have coffee chats like we have
once in a while
um and i can tell you that for me i try
to really balance
both because i'm kind of a nerd so it's
important for me to
to put the effort and like make sure
that the classes that i'm taking i'm
taking very seriously because i want to
take the most out of it but also
meeting new people having um coffee
chats and like having some fun with
new friends and expanding my network
it's super important for me this is
maybe the main reason why i came here so
i put a lot of effort
there as well so
very meaningful service in the
intelligence unit in the idf
years of experience in the field an
engineering degree six years at google
now very soon an mba from stanford
where are you headed and what are you
really passionate about like what do you
really see yourself digging into and
making an impact in what field
that's such a tough question um
to be honest i'm not sure what's the
answer for this question yet
i can tell you that i did my last six
months i worked as a product manager at
brex
brexit is a super cool company fintech
company
now valued at three billion dollars um
yeah true undergrads though they didn't
graduate but yeah
um and i really enjoyed my
time there i really loved product um
it's the first time that i'm doing that
so building something
and like thinking about the problem what
the users really want
thinking about the solution how to
design it then going through
the marketing stage and how do how do we
launch the product i really really
enjoyed that
so the way that i see it i would love to
do something around
product um and i also really enjoyed
fintech so this is this is an area that
i am passionate about i think
so many things are happening right now
in this space
um innovation is just waiting to happen
this is how i feel
um so this is something that i'm very
very passionate about
but we'll see i don't know i want to at
least for now just to keep
the opportunities open um and we'll wait
and see
right is there a specific experience
that you've accumulated so far that you
can really pinpoint and say this is
something that
that i learned a tremendous amount
something that may not be too obvious
specifically from brics either bricks or
any other any of the other job because
one of the things that i'm especially
curious about especially through this
show is the non-linear career pathways
that people take
and like you like many others it's a
non-linear career it's
you're moving from the idf to studies to
a corporate to a business school
and you've get you're getting all these
incredible experiences that i'm sure
that
when we'll do this chat again in 10
years after you've impacted millions of
lives with whatever you'll do
uh it's it's always interesting for me
to gather this
insight from along the journey so what
are some pivotal moments in your life
that you were
that you really are going back to and
thinking wow i'm so glad that i had that
experience even though maybe
i didn't realize the value of it at that
moment
i'll give you an answer that i'm not
sure you're gonna like but i'll try
i think that one of the most important
things that i learned
that change is always positive always
um doing a change going outside your
comfort zone you always learn a lot
and the things that are most important
to learn about
are the things to understand what what
you really want to do
what really interests you not everybody
knows it like what are
what is the perfect job for you uh why
you want to be an entrepreneur
is it really the thing for you why you
want to go to product why you go
like try to understand exactly what
you're looking for like
what is your perfect role what is your
perfect company and try to understand
the why
i think these are kind of the questions
that i've been asking myself a lot
lately
um and these are the type of questions
type of answers more accurately that
will help me shape
my next step and understand what kind of
job i want to do that will make me
feel happy make me feel like i have a
huge impact
[Music]
so and every time that i did a change
that helped me to take another step
forward to understand
the answers to those questions
amazing maya i want to thank you again
for being so generous with your time i
did like that answer very very much
and i want to thank you also for being
such a pivotal and important part of my
journey at stanford so we are countless
coffee chats and your help
with everything and it's it's warming so
to have such a strong israeli society
within stanford like half of my
professors somehow every quarter are
israeli which is just phenomenal
but having classmates and people that i
can look up to like yourself that
that are helping along the journey so
thank you for that before we go i have
the last question the most important one
three words that you would use to
describe yourself
that's a tough one um
okay for me will be friend
curious and problem solver you'll give
me the last one as
as if it was the one word it's there's a
hyphen in there exactly
friend curious and problem solver maya
thank you very much to nagaba best of
luck with finishing this year at the gsb
i definitely hope to see you either in
january or in march
er when i'm when i'm finally back in
campus and i can be in that wonderful
weather
not that it's it's not that bad in tel
aviv i have to say the weather
but i think there's less protests on the
streets of stanford right now
but i'm looking forward to seeing you
again soon thank you michael
looking forward bye-bye thank you